okay now at this point I've got to go
back to being old-fashioned no this is
the better one let's take this and let's
finish out I'm trying to find a formula
for this guy for s n for the series the
sum of the first n terms so if I take
out a factor of SN from the left hand
side what does that leave me with on the
left hand side once I factor it out just
on the left hand side yeah there's one
of them there and there's are lots of
them there so it'll be one - are you
okay with that okay yeah are you talking
about this line to this line okay so I
just want to do some factorization I
don't want SN minus R I just want that
can I by itself so if you think about
like changing the subject in any normal
algebraic situation
I just want to single one of them so
I'll factorized it out in a similar way
to how you might factor I say if I have
5x minus x squared
you can factorize an X out of that
country right so you'd write that as X
outside of five minus X you divided each
of those that's exactly what I've done
here is that okay it's just a bit
Messier cuz I've got all these letters
flying around some of you might be able
to anticipate what I'm going to do on
the right-hand side how can I simplify
it I can factorize this common factor of
a this time so I take that out what does
that leave me with
one - careful careful R to the power of
n and I'm just one step away from the
formula
I was after right I just want this by
itself so what should I do to both sides
divided by 1 minus R so here is our
formula put a big box around it the sum
of the first n terms of a geometric
progression is this it's a bit of a
monstrous looking fraction but this is
it this is what you will find waiting
for you on your reference sheet the
formula is it doesn't explain where it
comes from doesn't tell you what a is
what a first term doesn't tell you what
R is what's our common ratio doesn't
tell you what n is it's the number of
terms but this is the formula that it
gives you okay now quick note before I
let you have a go at using this John
like the sum of an AP there's more than
one way to say the sum of a GP right for
example it's the same formula but I
could dress up differently if I
multiplied the denominator by negative
one if I multiplied the denominator by
negative one what would you end up with
what happens to this when you multiply
my negative one yeah negative one plus R
which I could write in a more nice order
I would write it as one sorry I minus
one do you agree with that if I did the
bottom by negative one I should do the
top so what happens when you multiply
the top by negative one what happens to
these guys in the brackets just like
these swapped order these also swap
water so you could write the same sum in
this way these are not two different
formulas it's the same formula just
dressed up differently now I'm not gonna
tell you just yet why you might be
interested in writing it this way versus
that way you're gonna discover it soon
enough
but both of these and in fact this is a
third form I'm not telling you about yet
because less important but both of these
are ways to calculate the sum of a GP
can we quickly do an example can we cook
you're doing before I had written to
6:18 dot dot okay
so perhaps I want to know what the sum
of the first say seven terms write the
sum of the first seven terms I don't
even know what the seventh term is but I
don't need to to be able to use this
help me fill it in what's a in this case
two fantastic
I'm going to for reasons that become
clear in a second I'm going to use the
second formula have a think about why I
might use this one rather than that one
what's I what did we identify it's in
this case it's three that's the common
ratio how many terms did I say I was
interested in seven I wrote it right
there okay seven minus one and then on
the bottom I've got three minus one so
now I can just sort of simplify a little
bit how convenient
three minus one is two so I'm going to
cancel their three to the power of seven
okay guys
me out 39 27 81 243 729 I'm pretty sure
2401 is the next one I was thinking of
powers of seven I'm Nydia two thousand
one two thousand one hundred eighty
seven take away one so now I have an
answer okay yeah sorry I get my paws
mixed up all right now I'm a math
teacher not a calculator now what's
brilliant about this is that I don't
need to I can avoid so much work I don't
even know what the seven terms are but I
can still already work out what they add
up to and if you think back to that
truck dropping off gravel before you
know how we're like I know the total
distance I might know the total and
being able to calculate things on the
basis of that directly without wearing
all the intervening terms can really be
a time-saver okay so I'm gonna hit pause
there
oh no I tell a lie can you tell me why
why did I use this one rather than this
one which is the one we actually landed
on any suggestions say again
okay it was this thought you were
thinking Taylor so I could have I could
have done everything with this first
formula right but do you notice I'll
have a one take away three yeah gross
and you're gonna have a negative here as
well you have two negatives they'll
cancel they'll still give you the same
answer but I might as well avoid the
negatives if I can't ya know asked what
the third form was I wasn't going to
tell you that textbook does show you
what it is but I'm gonna I'm going to
show you show you where it comes from
I'm gonna take this like so mmm that's
right okay I'm gonna take this in you
know when we had a look you've got your
piece of paper they're just gonna borrow
this one you know how we turn to the the
sunburn AP into its other version
remember how we did that we took
advantage of the fact that we knew what
this guy was remember that we know what
that was
thank you sure what is this for a GP we
just wrote it down write a R and minus 1
which is hiding kind of tucked away in
here isn't it
totally is we can factor out one of the
odds right
it's a n minus one times odd do you
agree with that it takes a second to see
it you got to think about your index
notation there right - a on R minus one
so that guy there see that that's the
last term so I could if I wanted write
it like this this formula tends it it
turns out isn't as useful which is why I
didn't show it to you it's not on the
reference sheet but it's true just like
the others are true does that make sense